Oh
okay good
all right so now I'm gonna actually
start the lecture so the last three
video lectures were on the fast Fourier
transform but before that's we looked at
the continuous Fourier transform which
was this infinite integral over an
infinite domain okay so it took our
Fourier series which is defined on a
small periodic domain and we extended
that domain to go to plus and minus
infinity okay so that was the Fourier
transform and so what we're gonna be
able to do now is use the Fourier
transform to solve partial differential
equations on infinite domains and that's
what I'm gonna do today so I'm gonna use
the Fourier transform to solve a heat
equation a one-dimensional heat equation
on an infinitely long steel rod and
we're going to start thinking about how
we can use these transform coordinate
systems so the sines and cosines
coordinate system to solve partial
differential equations more easily okay
and today is Wednesday so there will be
class today and on Friday and on Friday
I'm going to go more numerical so today
is going to be like a whiteboard lecture
and then on Friday we're going to do
computer stuff so we're gonna solve PDE
s on infinite domains
and in particular we're gonna solve the
1d heat equation so what whenever we
solve the heat equation before what kind
of domains and we solved the heat
equation on sorry a defined space like a
rectangle I think we also solved not
necessarily the heat equation but
Laplace's equation on a circle I think
we solved it on a rectangle with two
different types of boundary conditions
we had a fixed temperature and
insulating boundary conditions and we
also solved it on like a fixed interval
in 1d okay a bunch of different ways
okay so now we're going to be solving
the 1d heat equation on the entire real
line and so the picture that I like to
think about this is that we have our
very thin but infinitely long steel rod
and this goes to you know X to positive
infinity and this also goes X to
negative infinity and I'm gonna have
some initial temperature distribution so
I have some some initial temperature
distribution that I'm gonna call u of X
at time 0 so I have some temperature at
all space but at defined at time 0 so if
I had my heat equation on a finite
finite piece of steel from 0 to 1 what
other information would I need boundary
conditions so what kinds of boundary
conditions could I use for a finite
length piece of steel
yeah so I could have something from
negative L to L and I could fix the
temperature at the endpoints forever I
could say there is equal to a and B or I
could fix the flux through the boundary
conditions I could say that they're
constantly pouring heat or absorbing
heat at a fixed rates but here when I
have an infinite domain things are a
little bit different so what are
reasonable boundary conditions for this
problem at the kind of infinite ends of
this this rod what do you think should
probably happen probably go to zero I
don't think it would make a lot of sense
to have an infinite amount of heat
energy in this rod so I want them to
taper off to zero so I kind of have that
these temperature distributions are
asked them toting to zero as X goes to
plus and minus infinity okay good
what is our 1d heat equation look like
what is the actual equation the partial
differential equation
right UT so the first derivative of my
temperature with respect to time equals
okay I have some second derivative of my
heat of my temperature with respect to X
twice and I have some constant out front
and what can that constant be has to be
positive so at one of the exercises I
haven't decided if this is a homework
exercise or what would be to try to
solve this equation just like what we're
doing but for a negative thermal
constant things are gonna go really
badly so you need a positive a positive
constant here you could have maybe I
should not mix notation so this is
partial squared u partial x squared and
another way to write this is u T equals
alpha squared u xx okay that's the heat
equation that's always been the heat
equation if this was in higher
dimensions I would replace this with
laplacian of u which would be partial u
partial x x partial u partial y plus
partial u partial as easy as many
variables as i have okay and I have with
initial condition U of X at time 0
equals f of X I just have some initial
temperature distribution so this is
equal to f of X and then the last thing
I need so I'm essentially writing down a
well posed problem and so whenever you
get a homework problem or an exam
problem you're gonna be thinking to
yourself is this problem well posed I
have a equation good I need an equation
I have some domain that this equation is
defined on and I have some initial
conditions and boundary conditions okay
so my boundary conditions are
essentially I'm just gonna write this in
shorthand so we have u the magnitude of
my temperature and also the magnitude of
the first derivative of my temperature
go to zero as the my spatial variable
goes to infinity this is just shorthand
to say that this could be you know the
absolute value of these goes to 0 as
goes to plus or minus infinity is the
magnitude of mexico's gets large okay so
there are a couple ways to solve this
problem one of the things we've already
learned is separation of variables so
separation of variables is probably the
most robust way of solving any linear
partial differential equation we can
always almost always do it it makes a
lot of sense and it's kind of a
procedure where you you know you can
solve the system in terms of these
eigenvalues the second way we can solve
this problem is to take the Fourier
transform of this equation to take the
Fourier transform of our temperature
with respect to space X okay so that's
the what we're gonna do today so I think
you should try to solve this using
separation of variables and see what you
get it would be a pretty simple you know
30 minute exercise and it's a good thing
to try probably 30 minutes if you don't
care that much about all the signs and
all the details but you can get a
feeling for it okay so we're gonna
Fourier transform and we're gonna
Fourier transform in space okay so we
have we have an infinite spatial domain
from plus and minus infinity and so
we're gonna Fourier transform in space
because we know our Fourier transforms
are defined on infinite domains we're
gonna Fourier transform in X and what
we're gonna get we're gonna turn our PDE
into an OD e which is awesome we know
how to solve OD es remember last quarter
was way easier all of these or a lot
simpler so we're gonna get an OD e in U
hat where u hat equals the Fourier
transform of U of X in time okay
maybe I should be a tad bit more
explicit U hat of Omega NT right my
spatial variable X when I Fourier
transform turns into a frequency
variable Omega but it's still a function
of time I'm not for you transforming in
time time is a constant with respect to
this Fourier transform
okay make sense so far and please
interrupt at any point like this is you
know important to see how this all goes
so I want you to interrupt if you have
questions okay I should probably write
down a Fourier transform integral at
some point because I we just realized I
didn't do that so I have u hat of Omega
T equals the integral from minus
infinity to infinity of my function U of
X and T times what what do I do to
Fourier transform e to the I believe
it's minus I X Omega D X wikipedia says
there's a minus sign here and my old
math you cure fill Holmes also says
there's a minus sign here the book I was
using does not have a minus sign here
and it's wrong I think so let's just go
with this for now so that's the Fourier
transform right we derived this as the
limit of a Fourier series as L goes to
infinity okay and we also showed at the
very tail end of lecture 15 but the
Fourier transform of U X is equal to I
Omega times the Fourier transform of u
right so that's just I Omega u hat
awesome that's way simpler always or you
think it's gonna be way simpler so the
Fourier transform of u xx is just I
Omega squared which is minus Omega
squared u hat and the Fourier transform
of u you know xx x would be minus I
Omega cubed for X's would be plus Omega
to the fourth and so on so this is just
multiplies I Omega every time I take a
derivatives which is a very nice
property and the last property is that
the Fourier transform of partial u
partial
remember this entire Fourier integral is
purely with respect to X and so time can
be considered a constant with respect to
this integral on X and so this partial
can pop out and this equals partial
partial T of the Fourier transform of U
which is equal to u hat sub T ok so this
is great
what we have here are you know the
Fourier transforms of all of our
variables of interest we can Fourier
transform u u X u xx + u T and what we
get is a way to transform our partial
differential equation so we have u T
equals alpha squared u xx and we're
gonna do this Fourier transform for you
and what I'm gonna get is u hat T equals
constants just pop out of the Fourier
transform the Fourier transforms a
linear linear so the constants pop out
alpha squared minus some times minus
Omega squared so minus alpha squared
Omega squared u hat right u xx is just
minus Omega squared u you have okay this
is amazing we just went from a PDE to an
Eau de right there's no there's only one
partial derivative in this so it's with
respect to time there's no partial X's
anywhere so this is just an Eau de a
first order linear ordinary differential
equation in U hat with respect to time
ok
and we know how to solve these ok
questions about how we did that or why
this is an eau de or anything yeah so we
got this from lecture 15 and essentially
we did integration by parts so this is
the integral of you know you write this
as what is it so the Fourier transform
of UX you have this integral minus
infinity to infinity of partial partial
X of U e to the minus I Omega X DX and
this is a terrible you know we always
call them U and DV but this is called
use this is really confusing but you
would say that this is the integral of u
times DV right this is a differential
and then that would equal UV minus the
integral of VDU
and everything just pops out because D U
is has a minus I Omega out front okay
and it would be a minus minus I Omega
cuz it's minus the integral of UDV
okay so that's how you get this property
okay good question it's always a little
difficult when there's a week between
lectures and this is a really really
important property so I'm glad glad you
asked okay other questions
make sense so far okay so let's look at
our OD e we have partial partial T of U
hat equals lambda times u hat where
lambda equals minus alpha squared Omega
squared those are numbers as far as time
is concerned those are numbers okay so
this is what my OD e looks like u hat
dot equals lambda u hat and what's the
solution so u hat of as a function of
Omega and T and it equals what e to the
lambda T e to the lambda T that's e to
the minus alpha squared Omega squared T
times u naught which is and what's the
not it's 0 in time so that's u hat of
Omega comma 0 and time that's the
solution let's see if this is what I'm
supposed to circle this is what I'm
supposed to circle this one is important
ok this is incredibly simple we get an
ordinary differential equation in every
frequency for every Omega this is an
ordinary differential equation that's
just a number this is just an ordinary
differential equation and this is the
solution and it's solution is a function
of Omega but that's totally fine ok so
how do we get u hat of Omega at time 0
how do we get u hat of Omega at time 0
sorry from the definition yeah from the
definition why not good why not just
from the definition plug in time zero
that seems totally reasonable this you
know at times zero it's still a function
of X I can still Fourier transform it so
u hat of 0 and Omega a function of Omega
at time zero is just the Fourier
transform of my initial condition this
is just equal to the Fourier transform
of U of X at time zero which is equal to
the Fourier transform of f of X this
little function f of X and if we want to
be cute we can call it s hats L Omega
that's totally fine
right the Fourier transform of my
initial conditions is just f hat of
Omega okay this is wonderful we have a
solution to our partial differential
equation but we're still in the stuck in
the frequency domain right we have a
solution but it's in terms of omegas and
we live in space we live in X's okay so
let's let's just write this out and get
back so the solution to the 1d heat
equation on infinite domain is the
following we have u hat of Omega and T
equals F hat of Omega times e to the
minus alpha squared Omega squared T ok
I'm gonna be a little bit slow here
because I want to start building up our
physical intuition for what the
solutions okay so this is just our
initial conditions in Fourier coordinate
system in Fourier domain what is this
function do
what is this function even look like
exponential decay of so what what do we
think of this as a function of what's
this a function of frequency and time
let's think of it mostly as a function
of frequency and that function of
frequency changes in time okay so this
function of frequency is does it have a
special name and I visited his
birthplace last week so this is a
Gaussian okay we have a Gaussian and you
know this is a Gaussian in Omega and the
variance of this Gaussian spreads out it
increases with time right the variance
is given by the square root of minus
alpha squared t so so I can kind of
rewrite this as e to the minus alpha
squared T Omega squared and this is
related to my variance and this is my
spatial my my frequency variable so this
is a Gaussian in Omega and it spreads
out as time increases you can plot this
plot this in MATLAB and you'll see that
it's a Gaussian it's a bell curve and it
spreads out as time increases okay cool
so what's happening is that another way
you can think of this you said
exponential decay and you're absolutely
right that this is an exponential decay
in time and what that means is that all
of my frequencies of my initial
condition are decaying I had this nice
initial condition distribution I could
write it in the frequency domain by
taking a Fourier transform and all of
those frequencies are dying out in time
and they're dying out at different rates
some of them are dining out faster some
of them are dying out more slowly okay
so what's happening is that the heat
equation the solution of the heat
equation is damping out it's killing all
of the frequency content of my initial
conditions all of the variations are
getting spread out uniformly until
eventually I'm going to have a uniform
zero temperature and
rhod I just gave away the ending of this
story but that's that's basically what's
happening you can already see it in the
frequency domain before we even inverse
transform okay so I like to use colors
here I'm gonna say that this is the red
part of the equation and this is the
green part of the equation and what
we're gonna do now is we're gonna
inverse for you transform this to get
our solution in space right we have our
solution and frequency
let's inverse for you transform it and
get a solution in space okay and in the
next lecture what I think we can do this
is either for the next lecture or for
homework for is we're actually going to
start plotting solutions of this for
different initial condition
distributions because it looks neat okay
so we want to go back to space where we
live okay so to bring this back to space
we inverse Fourier transform okay
there's three nasty integral steps but
they're not that nasty and I'm going to
take the worst part and just tell you
what the answer is this was the worst
integral I've ever done and I'm not
gonna make you do it so so my
temperature as a function of spatial
variable X and time T is given by my
inverse Fourier transform of the
frequency domain solution so what's my
inverse Fourier transform maybe you can
just read it to me one over two pi minus
integral infinity to infinity of this
nice expression here whenever let's say
that there's some red brackets stuff my
function big red bracket of stuff times
each of the positive I Omega X D Omega
sound right that's the inverse Fourier
transform I have a 1 over 2pi here
because you need it to be if you want
the inverse to be the identity the
inverse composed with the Fourier
transform should be the identity if I
need this 2pi here some people put a 1
over square root of 2pi on each of the
Fourier transforms but I like this one
better it's easier ok so the stuff
inside the red integral I'm going to
expand this green part out as another
integral I need to do that to solve this
ok that's why I wrote it in colors like
this so the green part what's the what's
f hat it's the integral ok it's the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of f of X I'm gonna use a dummy variable
I'm gonna call it f of Y e to the minus
I Omega Y dy that's that's f hat ok
that's my green piece and then the other
piece is e to the minus alpha squared
Omega squared T ok this isn't super
complicated right I'm just taking the
inverse Fourier transform of that
expression in the red brackets and I'm
expanding out F hat so that it's written
in terms of so so it's explicit what I'm
talking about here and I'm using a dummy
variable Y because it would be super
confusing if I used X okay now what I'm
gonna do is the following
neither of these terms has a Y in them
and so I can take this dy and I can
bring it out farther so I can bring this
entire thing into a big double integral
and I can group different exponential
terms so I can take e to the I Omega X
minus y
times e to the minus alpha squared Omega
squared T times f of Y I'm just
regrouping the insides and I'm making a
double integral so this equals 1 over 2
pi double integral both of them from
minus infinity to infinity of e to the I
Omega X minus y minus alpha squared
Omega squared T times F of Y and it's dy
D Omega stopped me at any point if this
becomes confusing or weird or if I do
something wrong but it's pretty straight
standard I'm just rearranging stuff ok
now what's nice about this double
integral is I can switch the order of
integration I can integrate Omega first
and then Y it doesn't matter and that's
what I'm gonna do so I'm going to bring
this and this function of Y doesn't have
an Omega in it so I can bring D Omega in
here and what I'm going to get is the
following this is equal to the integral
from minus infinity to infinity of 1
over 2 pi integral minus infinity to
infinity of this expression D Omega each
of the I Omega X minus y minus alpha
squared Omega squared T D Omega times f
of Y dy
this is all simple integration tricks
okay but now this integral is starting
to look to me at least a lot like a
inverse Fourier transform of e to the
minus alpha Omega squared T so let's
zoom into this integral for a little
while so this is a little tricky we have
to zoom into this inside integral to
figure out what it means okay so we have
to figure out what this expression is so
we have okay so the stuff inside the
brackets is equal to the 1 over 2 pi
integral minus infinity to infinity of e
to the I Omega C times e to the minus
alpha squared Omega squared T D Omega
where I've introduced another dummy
variable C equals X minus y
this inside integral right here is e to
the I Omega C times e to the minus alpha
squared Omega squared T right if I
multiply two Exponential's than the the
exponential parts just add so that's
what this inside bracket is and this is
exactly the inverse Fourier transform of
this thing I'm just in terms of this
dummy variable C okay so this is equal
to F inverse of e to the minus alpha
squared Omega squared T remember what
does this function look like in omega
diaochan right this is a gaussian
function now the really really nasty
integral that i don't want you to have
to do that I try to forget is that this
inverse Fourier transform this integral
here is also a Gaussian so this is an
extremely important fact that I don't
want you to have to verify the Fourier
transform of a Gaussian is another
Gaussian and the inverse Fourier
transform of a Gaussian is another
Gaussian this is an extremely extremely
extremely useful property this is one of
the most important facts about Fourier
transforms probably the second most
important after the derivative property
is the fact that Fourier transform of a
Gaussian maps to another Gaussian okay
so this equals another Gaussian and I'm
just going to tell you what it equals
equals e to the minus C squared divided
by 4 Alpha squared time this whole
exponential divided by 2 alpha square
root of pi times time okay this 2 alpha
square root of pi times time is my
variance
variance may be the standard deviation
it's one of those I think it's a
standard deviation and this is the
variance and that means that my variance
and my standard deviation grow as T
grows this thing spreads out as T
increases and remember this is a
function of space now this is X minus my
dummy variable Y okay so I'm going to
call this thing in here I'm going to
call this G hat of Omega and time I'm
using G because it's a Gaussian and then
we're gonna call this G of C and time C
is kind of it's a spatial like variable
it's it's in space but it's if X minus y
okay does the basic idea make sense I
take the Fourier transform or the
inverse Fourier transform of a Gaussian
I get another dowshen but it has some
weird variance and to compute this
integral to compute this integral here
right we have in the complex plane we're
trying to compute this integral it turns
out what you would do is you would
create a weird-looking box integral and
you would have some residue some poles
here and you would use all the coachee
integral formula stuff that we learned
in the first part of the class so you
actually can solve this integral using
complex integration theory but it's
horrific and I you can look it up on
Google ok inverse Fourier transform of a
Gaussian easy ok might be a good thing
to look at someday ok good so now we
know what this term is this inner term
here in the brackets is what it's the
inverse Fourier transform of my Gaussian
this is just equal to G of C comma T so
I have the minus integral integral from
negative infinity to infinity of G of X
minus y
and time times f of y DUI all of a
sudden it looks much much simpler okay
so this dummy variable C is really X
minus y and so I have my Gaussian that
funky Gaussian of X minus y comma T okay
what is this integral look like what
does this integral mean okay it does
look like an inner product but that's
not exactly what I'm going for it does
look a lot like an inner product but
this X minus y means that this is a
convolution integral okay
so how many of you remember convolution
integrals or I've seen them before okay
how many have not seen convolution
integrals before it's okay okay good so
for now I'm just going to tell you that
this is called a convolution integral
this integral is a convolution integral
and when we do Khan Laplace transforms
I'm going to really give you some
intuition for what the convolution it
means physically it's got very deep
physical meaning and I'll have time to
tell you that a little bit next week so
this equals this the notation for this
is G star F that's what this we call
this integral as G star F this is just a
symbol we use and this is a function of
X and T because I'm going to integrate
out my Y variable okay and this is
called convolution
okay so we're going to very shortly at
the beginning of next week we're gonna
start building an intuition for what
this convolution means physically and
I'm gonna start showing you what it
means right now it basically means that
all of my function f is gonna spread out
because it's being multiplied by a
Gaussian and integrated okay good so now
we're gonna take a big step back and
we're gonna think about physically what
we've learned about this system okay so
in the frequency domain we wrote down
our solution u hat Omega T and we saw
that it was our initial condition times
a Gaussian that was spreading out in
time okay and what that means is that
all of my frequencies all of my
frequency content of my initial
conditions were being damped out they
were dying out spreading out in time and
they eventually would spread out to to 0
because that Gaussian would eventually
become completely flat one of the
important properties of a Gaussian is
that it always has unit area underneath
the curve and so if I have infinitely
long variance and it's infinitely
shallow okay so what I have is my U of X
comma T equals this big nasty
convolution integral integral minus
infinity to infinity of e to the minus X
minus y squared divided by some stuff
for alpha squared T divided by 2 alpha
root pi T times f of Y dy this is my big
convolution integral and so U of X and T
equals convolution initial conditions
with a Gaussian so in words this is what
the partial differential equation is
doing we're convolving our initial
conditions with a gaussian we're
spreading
all of the variances and differences in
our initial conditions and the variance
of our Gaussian G in the variance of G
increases with time or with the square
root of time I think at the time the
standard deviation increases with square
root of time and so if I had imagined I
had an initial temperature distribution
this is X now or in space and let's say
that this is x equals zero so if I have
an initial temperature distribution
which is like a spike in temperature at
zero you can think of this as either a
really really big temperature in a small
window or you can even think of it as a
delta function if you like and the way I
think about this let's say I have my
steel rod and I just apply a blowtorch
to this location it's got a really big
spike in temperature big blowtorch spike
in temperature and then I turn the
blowtorch off and let it go what's gonna
happen I'm gonna spread out okay and I
wish I had a blue pen I don't have a
blue pen
I have a blue pen at my office but I
have a green pen here and so what
happens in very short times is that this
immediately spreads out and as time
increases it becomes more and more
spread out because my Gaussian has
higher and higher variance and
eventually this becomes kind of
infinitely shallow and there's zero
temperature everywhere all of the
thermal energy gets distributed across
all of infinity so this is physically
what we mean by convolving our initial
condition with a gaussian it's every
initial temperature disruption gets
smoothed out eventually and eventually
goes to zero and when we start plotting
this solution we're gonna see very
clearly that that's exactly what happens
in matlab this is not just some you know
I'm it's not just words I'm saying this
is actually what the equations are
saying okay that's basically what I have
are there any questions
that's a really good question so it's a
time-saver so numerically trying to
think of how to answer it's not exactly
a time-saver it's like we get a new
perspective on the system okay so we get
this entirely new perspective by doing
the Fourier transform which is that in
the 48 so in space we have space and we
have frequency domain right so we have X
and we have Omega and what we saw is
that in the frequency domain we had G
hat u equals G hat times F hat u hat is
just the product of my Gaussian times my
initial conditions but in space when I I
FFT when I inverse Fourier transform
this product of two functions becomes a
convolution of the rate of the functions
so this becomes u equals G star F where
G is the inverse Fourier transform of G
hat F is the inverse Fourier transform
of F hats and now this product becomes a
convolution in space so this is one of
the major properties that we find is
that it's actually simpler in the
frequency domain the product of this
Gaussian was very clear what was
happening we were damping out every
Fourier coefficients at different rates
according to this Gaussian decay in
space it's a little less clear this is
what we would get from separation of
variables so I actually like thinking
about the system in the frequency domain
because it makes a lot more sense we
have damping of all of the frequency
components of my initial condition and
getting this this sentence you know that
the solution is
volution of my initial condition with a
gaussian will find that that's really
the benefit of working in the fourier
and the laplace domain is that we get
this very very simple physical intuition
and that's given by this connection so
I'm gonna elaborate more on why this is
important on on Monday and we're also
going to see that this allows us to do
numerical computations so we're actually
going to do computations in the
frequency domain and everything is going
to be much much simpler than doing
computations in the spatial domain it's
more accurate it's faster it's easier to
code okay all right thank you
you